javascript a high level single threaded
garbage collected interpreted or just in
time compiled prototype-based
multi-paradigm dynamic language with a
non-blocking event loop made famous for
building websites it was created in 1995
in just one week by brendan ike with the
goal of adding an easy to learn
scripting language to the netscape
browser it was originally named mocha
but the genius marketing people of the
time wanted it to sound like that sexy
new java language today it's a fully
featured language that continues to
evolve through the ecmascript standard
it's most well known for building
front-end web applications because it's
the only language other than web
assembly that is natively supported in
browsers however anything that can be
built with javascript will be built with
javascript like server-side applications
with node.js mobile applications with
react native or ionic and desktop apps
with electron it's an interpreted
scripting language but tools like the v8
engine and chromium use a just-in-time
compiler to convert it to machine code
at runtime it's also excellent at
handling i o intensive jobs despite the
fact that it's a single threaded
language made possible by a non-blocking
event loop that can queue up work in the
background without blocking the main
thread to get started create a file
ending in.js your code will start
executing from the global context use
the console to log a value with the
built-in debugger now think about where
you want to run this file is it a
front-end browser or a back-end node.js
server in the browser you can reference
it with a script tag then the browser
will execute it when you open that html
file on a website javascript is often
used to grab an element from the dom
document query selector will grab the
first button then we can assign it to a
variable with either var let or const
var is the og way to do it but is
typically avoided let is for variables
that can be reassigned while const is
for variables that cannot be reassigned
now to make the button interactive we
can add an event listener to it by
defining a function for the on click
event we can use the function keyword
here or the more concise arrow syntax
now the event loop will execute this
function whenever a new click occurs
functions are first class objects to
support functional programming patterns
but javascript also supports classes and
inheritance for object oriented patterns
even though it's single threaded it can
do work asynchronously with the promise
api which also supports the async await
syntax js code can also run on the
server thanks to the nodejs runtime
instead of buttons on a web page it
interacts with things like the file
system api execute your code on the
server by pulling up the terminal and
entering the node command this has been
javascript in 100 seconds hit the like
button and subscribe if you want to see
more short videos like this and become a
fireship pro member if you want to learn
how to do all kinds of crazy stuff with
javascript thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one